a new book that comes out tomorrow
reveals previously unknown details about
the 2016 Trump campaign and now one of
its top officials became a key witness
in the probe of Russian election
interference
her name is deafening she's author of
two plea or not to plea it's a story of
rick gates in the Muller investigation
spoke exclusively to gates who's been
convicted of financial fraud and making
false statements to the FBI Paula Reed
talked with Paula Brock about the book
Paula so here's a question is gates
still cooperating with investigators
good morning Gail yes he is he is
expected to testify in the Justice
Department's upcoming trial against
another longtime Trump associate Roger
stone and speaking publicly for the
first time gates reveals how he went
from being a close confidant of
President Trump to a convicted felon
the Trump campaign it was not a very
sophisticated operation but it was a
very effective and smart operation
former deputy Trump campaign chairman
Rick gates is speaking publicly for the
first time since he was charged by
Special Counsel Robert Muller in October
2017 Gates was by mr. Trump's side from
the very early days of the campaign but
he was frozen out after he came under
scrutiny in the special counsels
investigation for his lobbying work in
Ukraine his life was interrupted at one
moment everything stopped author and
journalist Daphne Barak who says she is
a close friend of the president's spoke
to gates about why he finally decided to
make a deal with Robert Muller and flip
on his former boss and Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort you'll have to
play and because it's millions and and
the government would just come with more
and more charges during his blockbuster
testimony against metaphor in the summer
2018
lawyers pressed gates on his past
infidelity as well as stealing from his
former boss Rick Gates is a convicted
liar why should we believe anything he
told you it was always be a stigma that
all these people are convicted Liars on
the other hand at the Malheur report
they found his testimony very credible
gates also opened up
- Brock about behind-the-scenes details
from the campaign we had a lot of things
to think about in the context of you
know who Donald Trump might want you
know as a potential running mate Gates
said vice president Mike Pence was not
then candidate Trump's first pick to be
you know candid he wasn't at the top of
the list at that moment and and
rightfully so I mean we had just started
and we had others to vet he revealed
that it was the first lady Melania Trump
who insisted pence be her husband's
running mate because she didn't think he
would run against mr. Trump in 2020
despite no longer being in the
president's inner circle in this book
gate speaks glowingly about the entire
Trump family though the author tells me
the president has not spoken with gates
about this book or his decision to plead
guilty but gates continues to cooperate
with the Justice Department as he awaits
sentencing on charges of financial fraud
and lying to investigators Tony all
right Paula thank you very much